hi I'm live right now
welcome to the stream chica is in my
armpit as you can clearly see hi people
how are you doing it's good to see
you're a good bother and you are good
bubs for joining me on this livestream
how are you it's good to see you
it has been 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 times 3 sleepies which means that
chica has gone to Snoozeville about 30
times and you guys have gone to
Snoozeville about 30 times as well but
I'm back as of a couple hours ago I am
back which is good because I've been in
Korea for a long time a very very very
long time now and it's good to be back
it was good to experience Korea
absolutely thank you everybody for
joining in if you've missed the
beginning of this there was absolutely
nothing important all the important
information is happening right now but
the most important thing is that I'm
back in LA I am home uh it's weird
considering that all the street signs
are not written in Korean and I don't
have to try to translate Korean attend
every second of every day but I was in
Korea for 30 days - a few days there -
go finish up a project but I was in
Korea for 30 days and a lot of crazy
things happened while I was in Korea the
are the most obvious of which is I saw
my family and any time I see my family
over in Korea it's it's always a strange
and bizarre time cuz number one I have
to translate for my cousin hyung bade he
speaks a little English and I speak a
little Korean and together we
to communicate in one way or another
yeah we got a ball P here we keep it
cook I missed you so much
and it's just so much I missed you so
much
so so so unbelievably so much but I'm
back I am very tired so if I say things
that don't make any sense or would get
me reported to the authorities I want to
go ahead and make a sweeping apology I
was not in the right mind when I will be
the person that would might say those
horrible things this was a lapse this
will was be a lapse in judgment that I
did have will make maybe I will make a
concerted effort from now in the future
and the past the future that I might
maybe say something horrible going
forward I am better
I will and also have been better than
this
okay I think I've I've covered my
apology for the entirety of the rest of
forever so now I could say whatever I
want
like I could I could do whatever I want
like this bubble no that looks terrible
no it looks a beam blush pop crush glow
you are now whatever just whatever makes
chica look the best okay so I know this
Hill that means hello in Korean I went
into going to Korea in the hopes that I
would be at least conversational
combined my two years of study from
studying Korean go there solidify my
understanding of it and come back and I
would be at least conversational in
Korean I failed miserably I I
overestimated my own capacity for
intelligence and I underestimated the
difficulty of the language in terms of
being able to speak it now I can speak
it a little bit I know a lot of vocab
and I can get around in ha Jung shooted
oh da ole like where's the bathroom like
I got the basics of survival down so I'm
pretty good in that department
I can say like boom chic jogging to sail
which means give me food and I don't
know if it's proper to go into a
restaurant and start shouting boom chic
do say all give me food I don't think
it's quite correct but if it's not then
I really have nothing else to say about
it yes she goes right here I don't know
why but my phone's freaking out right
now so I hope it's still going here but
I'm back in LA which means that I am
gonna be back in making that sweet
delicious content for you that I have
not been able to make for well over a
month time that being said I I will I
will read her in my time in Korea was
really good I loved it I got kind of
sick of it towards the end because just
I missed home being home and I've just
missed making things and I miss my book
she has not lifted her head from the
crook of my arm since she did I think
she missed me it's hard to tell cuz she
gets so frazzled when things are
different and she reacts so happily to
anybody so if she could have just
forgotten me and she's just who she is
but I think she's locked eyes with you
guys I'm not a hundred percent sure but
I'm pretty sure she's completely like
Biman to you guys right now so
I mean you're welcome you've got the
unadulterated attention of chica right
now so whatever you want to say to chica
the floor is yours I suppose yeah so
cream was very good I can't I don't know
if you can see but her tails white oh so
you guys are very sweet
oh are you good
I fine thank you hey listen okay
keep this on the down-low you keep being
a good girl I'll keep sneaking your
treats okay do we have a deal oh love
you so much
but sorry guys I just I gotta get all
the love in for this dog as much as I
can so curry was great I really loved it
I learned a ton I got to spend a ton of
time with my family I get to spend a ton
time with my cousin jung-bae your did
say um you Jung Joo Jung ah like all of
my extensive family Tomo flew in from
Japan I've got an aunt that lives in
Japan and in a cousin who lives in Japan
it's like I have all this family and I
was able to spend a good amount of time
and I was actually able to communicate
with them in not necessarily a elegant
way but I could say uncle ship oil which
means I want to eat or something like
that you know or not a cheap oil which
is the weather's good you know I could I
could say you know some things like that
and I've got a pretty fundamental like
grasp on the language thus far hey we're
heading to cook with my arm again you
take comfy for you
get yuge later little head she hasn't
really left my side since I got home
this was the longest I've been away from
chica sorry the longest I've been away
from chica so being here with chica
right now is really really nice ed I'm
glad that like I'm able to be here for
her and she's able to be here with me
can I just get everybody in chat if you
can just give a big old smooch for chica
I will Pet chica once every time that
you guys type pet in the chat and I
think that's that's a fair trade I think
that's good I'll just get started right
away cuz I know there's gonna be lots of
for the good girl tell her she's a good
girl
cuz she's such a good girl she didn't
see me for a month
I thought she'd forget about me it's the
longest bye bye we've ever had but I
came back I always do here we go okay I
gotta get the pets it gets a lot of pets
it's very good growth yeah very hairy
girl
it's okay got it you good she's such a
good girl okay so new things came out
while I was out number one
the drowned man came out okay the
drowned man to clear up a couple things
here's this live stream counts as my big
stupid dumb explanation of everything
that happened with the drowned man right
okay it has nothing to do with anything
else I've ever made there's no
correlation to it with any other project
I made it was just this [ __ ] project
that I thought about doing with Wade and
we talked about it I was just like I
filmed that like a week before I left
for Korea I did not have time to do that
and yet I did it and that's just the
kind of like [ __ ] energy I love I
love that kind of energy of just being
like I know I don't have time to do this
I'm gonna do it anyway because if I
don't do it now I'm never gonna do it
like that kind of energy I love that
great [ __ ] right so like that kind of
thing that attitude about it is is very
important for me because I'm a big
proponent that if if you overthink it
you'll think yourself out of doing it
and if you have an idea just go ahead
and do it and then decide if it's bad
after you've done it you don't get to
critique your idea before it's even like
existed if it's if it's all in your head
then it's all theoretical in the first
place in your gonna know if it's gonna
be good or not and it turned out so good
I got up a lot of licks and for doing
some great editing on the ground man but
I just I love the ground mad I I'm so
glad you guys love the drama man I love
there's so much fan art to so much
Vanner
left right and up down everywhere about
the drowned man and I like I can't thank
you guys enough for making it there's
there's so much crazy coolest
the people made about the drum man and
then the other project that came up is
edge of sleep the story podcast that I'm
a part of I'm I'm starring in I guess
it's it's like the first real acting
rule I've gotten something like that
it's a really cool story and they've
done an incredible job one of my
favorite things to do is sound
engineering I love sound I love I did
you know all the sound for most of my
projects I've overseen the sound in the
upcoming big project that I've got
neither of these projects that came out
with a big project that's coming out
that's around the corner sooner than you
might think so sooner sooner than you
might think
sooo sooner than you might think I don't
know what's most appropriate for it so
anything you might think yeah so uh edge
of sleep again so much fan art about it
like thank you guys it's so cool I love
seeing people take something that has
like no basic visual element to it and
making their own fan of their own fan
art about it and you guys really liked
that idea too ran with it really far
there's some really cool stuff that
people have made in terms of the edge of
sleep and if you haven't checked out the
edge of sleep yet there is a link in the
description below and I link it because
tomorrow is when the new episode comes
out for it there's two episodes already
you can listen to it through the link in
the description or pretty much literally
any podcast app that you have it's free
so really there's no risk and if you
just want to check out the trailer you
can do that oh really I really love Ari
there's a look at the description you
can check it out there's a trailer if
you want to check it out
if you're into story podcasts
which are like fiction narrative audio
dramas like this one's a really cool
idea I can't tell you much about it
without spoiling it there's a nice
trailer for it it's two minutes go check
it out link in the description and then
the new episode will be there tomorrow
so if you want to get caught up and once
there right now listen to it now before
the new one comes out also if you've
been following me on Twitter you noticed
that I got oh no oh she's cool she
didn't like me booping this me he didn't
like me Bo Peep she didn't come here
guys it's because you guys aren't
calling to her you have to call out
chica and chatter oh she won't come here
chica please chick I can't say I'm sorry
about this toy so chica what Amy bought
this toy Amy bought this toy for me to
give to chica I gave chica this toy
right when I left like the day that I
left I gave her this toy and I said I'm
gonna be back in just a few sleepies
just you sit tight
just a few sleepies and I'll be back and
I gave it to her
ami would send me pictures her just she
would not let this toy go I don't know
if it was because she connected it with
me some hour just because it's just
ridiculous colored platypus she would
not let it go so she was just so bad
chica why's your breath smell like
buttholes okay what is it I'm not gonna
say that word even if I apologize for
everything I don't think that's a bad
word but I'm not gonna risk it
I just got better I just got back and
I'm getting back to making sweet swanky
delicious content oh but what I was
gonna say is if you've been following me
on Twitter you know that I got a haircut
recently and you know this because my
haircut looks like I got in a fight with
a vacuum cleaner and lost badly I went
to the barber okay story time right my
mom who might be watching this hi mom
if my mom is here everybody say hi to my
mom she usually watches my thing I love
my mom very much she's a good mom she
has this thing where she has if she has
a suggestion it's not a suggestion she's
the type of mom that when she wants you
to do something she will badger you
coerce you just somehow make it so that
is the reality that it's happening and
you have no say in the matter
that's my mom so I was like when I was
in Korea I was like I I want to get a
haircut you know maybe get one of those
kpop haircuts maybe something like that
and I don't know how serious I was I
didn't want a kpop haircut that's for
darn sure but my cousin's young they
took me my mom and my little cousin
Salem the one I almost beaten arm
wrestling to this hairs
it was called j-style I don't know if
that has anything to do with anything
but I go there and there's a very
flamboyant looking guy I don't mean that
in an insulting way this guy this guy
exude colour this guy exuded loud his
personality was loud without him talking
that's the kind of guy this guy was and
I didn't understand a word he was saying
I've never encountered a person like
this that's speaking a different
language it was a fascinating experience
so this guy roughly translates through
my cousin not my mom my mom is not
translating anything for me my mom
speaks perfect English and perfect
Korean my mom does not do translation in
these scenarios it's always like my
cousin so it's like I'm hearing I'm
hearing very fragmented words like hair
cut and long and one side and I'm like I
don't know this is gonna go well for me
so uh yeah I I ended up getting what is
probably a very traditional Korean
haircut which is a bowl cut there's no
there's no other way to describe it I
this this ungodly beast that is great
it's this this horrific nightmare that I
am showing you because I know you'll
keep this between us I know that you
ain't gonna spread no image screenshot
of this because I am the first thing I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna fix this nightmare
as soon as I can book an appointment
it's like an animal died on my head I
don't know if it's because I have an
enormous head but I don't think I pull
off the generic Korean
bull cut hairstyle it somehow makes me
look like you know the the subreddit 13
or 30 when I have this I think I fit in
that subreddit ordinarily I don't
because I'm 30
but in this weird way I'm both at the
same time and it's not a thing I want I
don't want any way shape or form and I
can't explain because this was not a
bowl when I walked out of the salon
what it was was an up spikey like
nonsense it was like this I somehow
managed to recreate the exact like
experience except somehow even more
tousled tangled nightmare of hair and
when I walked out of there I I looked at
myself in the mirror and I took pictures
there are pictures on my Twitter oh this
hair it was like I was seeing myself
dying
I looked in this mirror and I saw like
my sub count I saw me sub count
plummeting my follows on Twitter
diminishing my my my likes on Instagram
just plummeting I every drain every
essence of cool then I had very hard fun
and I don't have a lot let me get one
thing straight I'm not cool but I had
amassed at least a little bit I feel
like I got a few cool point all of it
went away like all the cool points went
away all the cred I had just oozed out
of me and it was just vented out through
this weird hair that I had so so in long
story short is the worst haircut I've
ever had in my entire existence and all
my mom could say was so handsome so
handsome and my cousin was all most she
saw which is cool in Korea what she saw
good good haircut it didn't help them my
cousin had the exact same haircut except
the only difference was that mine was
spiked up in some way but between my mom
going like oh so handsome you look like
the kpop every while I'm just sitting in
my car seat dying and is slowly rotting
away inside so this is gonna get fixed I
don't know how but I'm gonna get it
fixed
I may have to chop it all off I may have
to go completely shaved again but we
will see about that
Oh for people with joining chica chica
come here I love you I love you I love
you Chico Beach is my pit accommodating
for you everything you've ever dreamed
of that's a good good that's so good
you're so good girl you're so good girl
you're so dot you're so needy sometimes
you're such a good girl you're a very
good girl you're so good
hi she's a very good girl
everyone please tell chika she's a very
good she's a very good girl please tell
GK she's a very very very good girl
Gary okay so anyway that doesn't scratch
the surface of my adventures in Korea
I'm sure they will come out in due time
but I just wanted to say I'm back I've
got a lot of really cool things planned
now that I'm back I've got this next
project is gonna blow your tits straight
off
I can't I'm not exaggerating when I say
that your tits are gonna be obliterated
when this next project comes out I just
cannot wait for you to see this next
nightmare of a project that's coming out
for you I can't spoil anything about it
but it is going to just annihilate your
nards you will have nothing left you
your entire face eyes nose mouth and
ears will be blown away it's gonna be
like the the Ark of the Covenant from
Indiana Jones when everyone's head
exploded that's gonna be you watching
this next series
I'm not exaggerate
it is so nearly here it's so ways away
but it's so considering how long I've
been working on it
been working on it the entire team have
been working on it it's it it's so right
around the corner right around the
corner and I've got some other things
that I wanted to do but also in basic
basic form I'm gonna get back into
regular video uploads and stuff like
that and playing these new games I know
there's this goose game that I've been
wanting to play for awhile there was a
lotta games not while I was in Korea
that I just wasn't able to do videos on
but III do want to get back into the
original intention that I had for going
to one video a day which was more
involved videos every day instead of
just doing content like I was doing a
Korea just to try to like stretch things
out but I will finish up Blair Witch and
then that's it and then more cool stuff
coming I'm very tired I apologize she
could come over here
Kabir let me get a good look at you
chika cover
come here chika Henry Henry Henry and
he's right there guys have you called
Maude enough Henry will pop up in his
dream Henry please oh no guys he didn't
he turned around Henry Henry she girl
who was too good to me Henry and he's
just laying down
I can't believe it it's not working okay
keep going here okay it didn't work
I'm sorry I had other things that I
wanted to talk about I've forgotten
everything I had a list but my list is
on my phone and I'm using my phone to do
this live stream so I can't exactly get
to the list of things I wanted to talk
about but anyway I think that catches
everybody up pretty much everything and
if I forgotten something I'll just get
it to it in another video in the future
but the most important thing to know is
that hum back cue baby I'm back by
schmoyoho the the remix they did of that
play that one after this one if YouTube
algorithm is listening to me and I'm
sure that they are that's how the
algorithm works
hey YouTube please suggest baby I'm back
markiplier schmoyoho remix as the next
video for this live stream and that's
what you guys will get and that'll be
the full understanding of what's going
on here anyway I'm gonna go take a nap
because I'm very tired
and my sleep schedule is gone and I will
never be able to get back on a normal
one ever again because Korea time is
literally like the opposite of us time
but now I'm back baby I'm back I'm on a
roll I'm back
and more content will be coming soon she
could come say goodbye please please
chiku can you come say goodbye
chicas get you some gum say goodbye
Henry can you come see the papaya and
you want to take a bite
see cuckoo cuckoo girl okay
she could go sick okay chica look for
you chica what did you do cheek goodbye
say bye bye say bye bye guys bye